Met Gala 2018 why Beyonce won't be
attending plus a look back at Rihanna's
remarkable looks from Met Gala past
hello you guys the biggest night in
fashion and the Internet's favorite
source for memes is here
I mean seriously from Kanye West's
contacts to Sarah Jessica Parker's
flaming headdress every year the Met
Gala turns out some jaw-dropping and
head-scratching moments from all the
stars on the red carpet and inside they
turn all the way up so expect my gala
2018 to be even more epic but if you're
at home waiting to see what Beyonce
shows up looking like don't hold your
breath a source tells et that Beyonce
backed out of tonight's Met Gala to
spend time with her husband quote jay-z
surprised her with the trip because he
felt she needed to relax before her tour
so in other words this is jay-z's home
okay obviously I'm being dramatic but
the couples on the Run tour is a month
away plus she did just spend months
cooking up that Coachella performance so
a surprise vacation sounds like it's
well-earned it's just that this year is
the second year in a row B has skipped
the gala last year she was still very
pregnant with twins Rumi and sir and
this year designer Peter Dundas who
designed Beyonce's looks for the Grammys
was set to dress her for the gala and
had been working for weeks on Beyonce's
gown so hopefully we'll get to see it
eventually so Beyonce won't be there but
you know who will be Rihanna rereads one
of the co-hosts for tonight's
star-studded gala and this year's theme
is heavenly bodies fashion and the
Catholic imagination and we know Rihanna
loves sticking to the theme the Barbados
Beauty has been rocking the red carpet
at the Met Gala for a decade now I'm
going Tom Ford and the procedure
looks great thank you yes of course I
know it looks really difficult to wear
but it's it's really stretchy very
cleverly made you take your mom to get
dressed tonight
no the dressing part was easy my nails
took forever
they're like claws why did you pick this
one
out of
I wanted it
she knows the fabric and we collaborated
on this with blanks it was fun Greeley's
Met Gala style transformation has gone
from simple wearing this white halter
with black mesh gloves to edgy in this
black pantsuit and those shoulders own
black lace and a long red braid sleek in
a black croc embossed dress then white
and showing skin but in 2015
RiRi literally dropped the mic when she
showed up in this gown weighed 55 pounds
and she needed three people to help her
up the famous Met steps the dress
sparked a ton of memes some comparing it
to scrambled eggs pizza and Big Bird now
that look was one to remember but I
gotta say I loved her costume last year
when she showed up looking like this
bouquet of flowers you know I can't wait
to see what Rihanna's got planned this
year and we hear our fave bad gal has
had a vision for her Met Gala look all
the way down to her shoes we got a sneak
peek of the custom shoes she could be
wearing down the red carpet depending on
what she likes best she has a silver and
gold option to choose from
alright as you can imagine these very
famous folks have been prepping for this
red carpet for a long time Kim
kardashian-west revealed on her app
she's been on a cleanse for the met but
the same can't be said for Katy Perry
she posted this in-and-out burger on
Instagram stories last night and said
she's stressed eating for the Met Ball
but you know what she's not alone Olivia
Munn and by the et to get ready for the
gala with her and she's been eating
cookies gives me a lot of stress I see
people working out and onstop on
Instagram talking about their cleanses
and their diets all for the Met Ball and
I had French fries the last two nights I
mean I I'm not it's not like it's so
easy for me to do that I mean it's it's
definitely something I'm going to regret
but I can't help it every time people
talk about how good they are I want to
be bad can you blame her
how you gonna turn down a cookie and
fries you know like I get it Olivia Munn
iced olivia is wearing this gold chain
maille dress which is custom made by H&M
the creation has 70 feet of gold rings
linked together by hand
and a three foot train guys I'm telling
you they do not mess around at this
thing but you know another starlet
you're probably not gonna see tonight at
the Met Gala is Taylor Swift Taylor
kicks off for reputation stadium tour in
Phoenix Arizona tomorrow on Saturday tag
game adoptive and foster families in
Phoenix a private show at her final
rehearsal et learn that Taylor performed
for 2,000 people during the special
rehearsal and that same day the singer
also spent some time with a local burn
victim who was recovering after a
horrible burn accident in March the
eight year old had apparently recorded a
video asking Taylor to visit her since
she couldn't make it to the concert so
sweet
alright guys the Met Gala is underway
and we have all the looks and interviews
with the stars on the carpet happening
over at ET online.com we'll break down
the most memorable looks tomorrow but
until then enjoy a look back on the 7
ensembles that define the Met Gala right
guys thanks for watching I'll see you
tomorrow